hello in this video i will explain
in a simple way what the p-value is i
will start with the question
what is the p-value how do i interpret
the p-value
and what is the difference between the
p-value and
the significance level afterwards i will
show you
how you can calculate p-value easily
online with data tab
for different hypotheses tests in order
to explain the p-value
let's have a look at this example in
this example we want to investigate
if there's a difference in the salary
between women
and men our assumption is that there's
no difference
in the salary so our null hypothesis is
there's no difference between the salary
of man
and woman in the population at the one
side
we have the population but for sure it
is not possible to ask
every woman and man from this population
therefore
we need a sample in this sample we also
have the salary from woman
and man so for sure although in the
population
there's no difference between the salary
in this sample
for sure there will be at least a small
difference
it is quite unlikely that the difference
will be zero
for example in this sample the result
could be
that the difference is 50 euro or
150 euro or 250 euro
even if there's no difference in the
population
but again the assumption is there's no
difference in the salary between men
and women in the population and now
we will come to the p-value the p-value
tells us how likely it is to draw a
sample
in which the salary of men and women
differ
by more than 50 euro or
the p-value tells us how likely it is
to draw a sample in which the salary of
men and women
differ by more than 150 euro
or the last example the p-value tells us
how likely it is to draw a sample in
which the salary
of men and women differ by more than 250
euro
so again we assume that there's no
difference in the population the p-value
now tells us
how likely it is to draw a sample
in which the difference between men and
women in salary
is 250 euro or greater although
there's no difference in the population
for example if we are using data tab to
calculate the p-value
and let's say for the salary difference
of 250 euro
there's a p-value of 0.0
and what does it mean if the p-value
at a difference of 250 euro is for
example
0.05 it means that
only 5 it is only five percent likely to
draw a sample
with a difference of 250 euro or more
if there's no difference between the
salary and the population
so if there's no difference
in the population it is only four
percent
likely to draw a sample in which
the difference in the salary is more
than 250 euro
so if the p-value is quite low for sure
we can ask if the null hypothesis is
true
in the population maybe the difference
in the salary difference is not
zero in the population so and now we
come to the question
at which point is it unlikely enough to
reject
the null hypothesis therefore we come to
the question
at what point is the null hypothesis
rejected
for this purpose the significance level
also called alpha level
is introduced it is very important that
the significance level is always
determined before the examination and
must not be
changed afterward in order to still
obtain
the desired statement
to ensure a certain degree of
comparability the significance level is
usually
five percent or one percent
the alpha level below one percent is
highly significant
below five percent is significant and
above five percent it is not significant
so and now we will come again to the
p-value
the definition of the p-value is that's
a probability
of the observed result plus even more
extreme
results if the null hypothesis is true
and let's have a look at our example
again what
does this mean if the null hypothesis is
true
is that we assume in the population
there's no
difference between the salary of woman
and man so we ask
what is the probability that we draw a
sample
where the salary differ by more than 250
euro
if in the population there's no
difference
for example this could be four percent
then this would mean
it is only four percent likely that we
draw
a sample where the salary
differ by more than 250 euro
if there's no difference in the
population
and now i'd like to show you how you can
calculate the p-value
with data tab for this example
to do this please visit first statist
the statistics calculator
at datatab.net and then
simply click at the statistics
calculator
in this table you can copy your own
data if you like or in this case we will
simply use
the example data now we can see here
our variables and we can see here the
different tabs what we can calculate
in our case we want to do a hypothesis
test
we want to calculate a t-test so we
simply click
here then we want to compare
the variable salary with the variable
gender so we simply click on salary and
gender in this case data tab
automatically calculate an unpaired
t-test and
if we scroll down we can see the p-value
in this case the p-value is 0.056
which means the result is not
significant
what does it mean here we can see the
difference between
men and women it's 711 euro
so if there's no difference in the
population
and the probability to draw a sample
which has a difference in the salary
which is
greater than this is only five comma six
percent it's quite low but it is not
lower than five percent we will not
reject the null hypothesis
i hope you liked this video and maybe i
will
see you soon bye